my name is kingsley bernadette and i
play malcolm x my name is eli goray
and i play cassius clay i am aldous
hodge and i play jim brown
i'm leslie i'm junior and i play sam
cook and we
the cast of one night in miami are here
with
buzzfeed playing a game of who's who
who's most similar to the black icon
they portrayed on screen
leslie leslie no argument for me i'll
take that
eli with those 3am workouts that's some
cash's dedication yeah yeah
no i had to work out before the call and
then after we wrapped so i'd work out
like three to like five
go to set through this day and then
after we wrap we go back to the gym
who's most likely to start singing
randomly on set
don't say me ho ho ho ho eli kingsley
i'm sure i said kingsley you said eli i
said me because i would always be trying
to sing your song
who's most likely to nail the scene on
the first day of me
oh
no it's true it's you it's true it's you
without question
who's most likely to be caught at craft
services
elon eli
yeah but only because i was like i had
to eat like a thousand million calories
a day so it's like
always eating who's most likely to break
character in the middle of a serious
take
i i didn't mean to throw you under the
bus there leslie i just remember there
was a one particular evening
that made me laugh when you when you
were breaking the character i'll tell
you what i remember a particular evening
when
kingsley scared the daylights out of
some carpenter in the back of the set
who was working when he should have been
silent during a take he was like hey hey
none of that none of that who's best at
giving relationship advice
how does me i give life advice
relationship advice
you miss me with that one yeah i try not
to give advice on that who's most likely
to start a podcast
about historical black figures
i only say that because i'm already
starting a podcast i can't spill the tr
yet
it's definitely about um uh social and
cultural issues that are going on so
yeah
that's in my wheelhouse who's the best
at doing impressions of
other cast members kingsley don't get
mad at me leslie because you know i love
this
i i mean it with all love but i
literally every day
at least once do the nationwide is on
your side
[Music]
and then with uh with kingsley i'd say
yeah bro
because i was just you know i was in it
you know when you're in it you know
you're not messing around there's no
messing around right
and then with um this let me see uh i
mean i'm just a different kind of dude
man you know back in the days they had
that different kind of box and you know
when it comes to me i'm trying to really
uh really pontificate about this
that's what i said i'm like pontificated
man who's most likely to win a game of
regina king
trivia eli all day yeah i love all of
her films i'm a huge uh
admirer of her i mean i think all of us
all of us can answer the questions i
talk about it the most but all of us
have mentioned
the fact that you know we're all of them
bro
take the crap but i feel like a team
effort like we all love regina we all
respect what she's done we all know all
her films
who's most likely to make regina king
laugh from behind the camera you gonna
have to ask
gina i don't know who y'all think i said
you i was gonna i said you too i said
i'll do it yeah probably
i'll take it a lot of the levity i think
in the film that comes through
jim and catches you know is the charisma
of the men
that they were playing but also the
charisma of the actors aldous played
some of those moments with such
truth that they they were funny even
in the room you know what i mean who's
most likely to pull a prank
on set you're really serious on that set
serious we missed a lot of opportunities
we should have been pranking each other
the whole time
you